hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the end is not we're
in the air in flats
we got problem oh he's had a cellar to
mer yeah it is we're back in the arid
flats which we've just got to so we're
not technically back at it okay we're
fine excuse me is that a damn it I was
right there oh damn you damn you to hell
and back well there we go
excuse me excuse me a masseuse bleep I
gotta get me this guy here alright uh-oh
can I not get up there I'm now hello oh
there's got to be a way to get up yeah
but I don't have it just yet
so I get it later alright okay thank you
oh where am I going oh oh that ain't
good
okay squish that guy oh it did oh I
didn't actually think that was gonna
work okay alright hope oh boy apparently
there's a way if you nope that ain't it
so if you hold
so you can squash I didn't know you
could squash with right trigger you can
squash doosh doosh
oh no oh no [ __ ] shitty dicks welp that
didn't go our plan go ski alright wait
wait for this wait for my go no no that
was not my go alright wait Han everybody
hold on hold on to your britches okay I
made it so I just gotta get past this
and find out the why of all this
[ __ ] that I am in you didn't think I
was gonna make it but there's gotta be a
way to get both cuz I know there's gonna
be more secrets around the nice okay got
that come back here that's my ride Oh
God my ride wants to kill me woo shitty
dicks who are you wait a minute wait who
are you Oh would you like to see your
flag this ride requires 50 lifetimes of
suffering to entry please return when
your tumor has grown we will be waiting
all righty bye men need more tumor I'll
get you more tumor I suppose [ __ ]
goofy bastards everything I don't even
know what these things are if everyone
if everything here is supposed to be
done little bit mistake oh if everything
here is supposed to be camping what are
these things where all the tumors alive
and none of this makes any sense you
know what it's okay because I'm about to
die
oh god damn the timings off on this son
of a [ __ ] if you could just give me a
ride though here we go
we're good now everything's fine I'm
happy I do ski so I got to come back
when I get 50 tumors well that's gonna
be one ooh
pile of bones Shh there are others close
by
crazies who believed in what they called
the Ascension they hide just out of view
some are above some of the lows don't
try to find them and definitely don't
speak to them stick to the linear path
kid exploration can only lead to
disappointment I explored myself once
and I'm dead
think about it I'll think I'll [ __ ] I'll
think about it
whoo nailed it dangerous okay I like it
well spooky about it but okay are you a
big tumor do you want to be my friend
god I love it the controls are so tight
oh it sounds weird when I say it like
that but that's I think that I like
about platforms right like the controls
are everything in a platformer so if you
don't have them treat you right then
you're gonna have a bad time up well so
let me yeah I needed to do that first so
that I get through there after this and
then either talk to that dude who again
I thought everything was dead here or
have that dude give me tumors those geek
ah damn it damn it how am I gonna be
able to there's a Ledge on the lube it's
not the words for it but there's a Ledge
on the edge of that one that I can grab
onto it's not the loo but but it's close
enough
oh I go Frick or I can use this nope
that's not how you get this
I died I love the music by the way music
is good I can't see Oh Frick you dick
ass ah funk you bunk bums
I gotta get over on the doobie I'm not
confident about this jump here but I was
right there goddamn it boy are we out of
rhythm
Rick a dunk freak my dunk dunk my
frickin maybe I should try to get on the
ledge before I go for that other dude
Zach could be four off [ __ ] oh man
that's that's a doozy of a Brad and I
don't know how I'm gonna do that I'm
brie I'm getting better at it like it's
surprising how fast I'm getting better
at this
hold jumpin oh wait for it got it nailed
it okay yeah I nailed it for you one of
us one of us gobble gobble gobble gobble
one of us one of us righty-ho then not
sure what you're talking about
Oh Oh No so now I just got to get that
tumor dude and then get up there which
now seems a lot harder for some reason
like I'm gonna [ __ ] this up I know I am
I've talked to the dude don't [ __ ] it up
it's easy it's super easy okay easy
peasy lemon squeezy can I go in the
water or not I feeling the waters gonna
kill me please don't [ __ ] up I have a
funny feeling my fuck-ups are on the way
where is this butthole go I don't want
to go back up yet did I get everything
that I need oh well there's gonna be
pile driving into death oh I could go in
the water you know I'm stupid and
Willie's take out everything okay
carrying on give me what I need not what
I don't know
you let me poke my eye out at you gotcha
I got you baby all right oh that's where
it teaches you that thing hey kid you
ever want to grab corners while running
it's easy all you gotta do is be ducking
what are you running the body wood to
snag on with the corner every time it's
a classic tactic I used once to escape
from Earth
don't worry we're nice now okay all
right then don't know what kind of urges
you're talking about but I want to know
that oh hey
hidey-hidey-ho neighbor neighbor renown
every no what are you doing who Gabourey
no all right well neighbor read oh boy
Oh oh no that was my ride no my ride ah
shitty dicks oh I know what I need to do
I just need to be uh not on that yet you
need to be that when I'm up here right
there no I gots closed oh yeah baby yeah
buddy
Oh goodbye dust motes okay I just got
through that whole shamrock all again
okay okay we made it
surprisingly it's had a strong move to
spawn I love sprung actually I'm getting
horrible flashbacks about sprung from
Mario maker oh I see you you think you
can sprung away from me oh you can as I
cannot sprung correctly no my magic
tumor bean i'ma wait here for you unless
I need to go down and come back well I'm
not gonna happen if I do that to myself
well also that so maybe I got over like
run back in time assume that's true okay
let's assume
just gonna wait here until the tumour
floats down from heaven I was right I
was right I'll take mine
ha got you perfect perfect
oh not almost not perfect but I got you
Hey
going going going skadoosh key well - hi
wing going skidoo ski well too low going
and going
don't well missed my target wing Boeing
skidoo skeet well goddamn it
ok so I just need to be holding well not
like that ok we're made it ooh Fricka
dick ok well we made that that's not an
extra oh that's a thing are you boys
doing over there
I need to come back up bet well uh I see
you I see my destiny where am i okay
well then I don't know where I went I
went away okay but it's gonna come back
if that's how this works
so I'm just gonna go up I'm gonna go up
well actually oh no I can get you soon
ah miss job for you come to Papa
oh you're so sad come into my arms
[Music]
gadget come on you freakin ass how you
ask
Oh give me a smooch gotcha gotcha
okay don't know where this is hitting me
whoa that was close II wait whoa speed
run baby
whoopee I don't need to be this stupid
up and over up and through the I didn't
go up enough my ops ops my ups ups and
my goons
oh come on hit the goddamn target ah
Punk Oh nailed it that's I'm maneuver I
call that one the maneuver god damn it
let me do my maneuver and get out of
here oh I almost had you I miss my
target got a mega tumor boink okay but
I'm gonna do that instead in point my
manoeuvre how do I get up there is there
a way to get up there I don't think
there is
yeah cuz right as it stands now maybe
maybe I could grab onto that ledge I do
not know but ever nope
maneuver nope maneuver boink boink yeah
no it's it's not high enough okay
well I al thread the Moodle baby and now
let me let me do this okay
well that's dead all right well I got
what I need so I gotta keep moving Oh
scary
got ya well that was easy wait a minute
what's down Wow
what's down here nothing what's down
here
nothin all right bye oh [ __ ] what's down
here nothing right
oh I see how you operate new ski what's
a book that's not oh I don't have a key
for that how am I supposed to do
anything about that don't get me
no no it's bad oh no I'm okay but I was
gonna rain right into that bevel hey hey
whoa whoa whoa oh whoa oh whoa whoa oh
whoa oh whoa oh whoa no well now you ski
pass that guy got rescued by me now you
have to be my son oh hey what are you
doing I'll bounce on you I got you
okay well that worked I didn't even know
that was gonna work but apparently that
work look be sorry thank you
I'm sorry that all right can someone
come here I need your head now Frank not
there not like that not like this not
like this give me your head no come on
ah [ __ ] you come on give me give me the
good stuff
no God ah - hi - okay yeah I gotta get
down
let me up let me someone let me up oh no
not like this not like this
[ __ ] you you're gonna be a dad card
chest whoa you're gonna be dead aren't
you oh you're gonna be dead aren't you
oh so close
somebody give me oh that's aa [ __ ]
tackle somebody whoa
pack me in oh oh okay well I'll take
that one well I'm up I'm up I'm up I'm
up I'm up where do I need to be up give
me my got that okay just get me up give
me my ups give me my ups give me my
goddamn ups
I don't know wool give me my goddamn ups
give me Mike no not like that
[Music]
[ __ ] a duck and just give me my goddamn
ups take just like that then give me my
goddamn offs nope now Oh
I had it I had it I had it I had it I
had it and then I lost it cuz I'm an
[ __ ]
goddamnit just give me my ops on my
morning ops
give me my up ok that's it and then you
come over here you all like that I hate
you what did you're okay but you're okay
I'm out I'm out I'm out baby oh well
that's no good okay honey - sure guchi
guchi
well never mind let me just sue he got a
good run and duck at the same time
because I'm about [ __ ] baller I'm not
gonna die alive this is called the game
where mark guys a lot oh that's my home
be whole
alright don't know let me just actually
checkpoint that okay okay easy peasy
I know how to do that got that on Lackey
Oh No well that's difficult ain't it
that's a conundrum oh there's nothing to
rescue me how do I get down there and
you go there oh that's how you do it
okay I got it I got it I got I got I got
Oh Frick
[Music]
oh that is a cool move that is a really
cool move I don't know how to get over
there though hello how are you doing
okay well gund I just thought I'd let
you see me explode into bits before I
actually converse with you
looks like I'm not actually gonna be
able to oh yeah I am I may look cute but
I'm really the one that haunts you
I'm the one that wakes you up at night
with those past memories you like to
forget I'm the one that reminds you of
your mistakes
I am death spooky huh really though
remember when you get the phone call
haha gotcha see you in your dreams All
Right see ya you're cute I like yeah
you're you're pretty cute I like that
about you you're pretty cute you're cute
on your cue and I like that this looks
dangerous
I don't know whether it's gonna take me
but here I go ooh that was almost
correct
not anymore lift okay this is gonna be a
doozy I can tell oh boy whoa
hippity-hoppity homeboy no that's a
hip-hop I don't want well yeah ah that's
the pet there's a pattern to these okay
yeah what have you come over here stop
jumping in the house No
no I didn't mean to come down here I
wasn't gone I wasn't done no no I wasn't
gone oh oh oh
well damn Dibley I have to go back for
the other one roof alrighty then you're
gonna be like that I'm gonna be like
this how do you like it some of your own
medicine here you ski
oh no I want that I want the thing oh I
got it
well I guess I'm gonna freak my dunkers
I gotta get out of it before I get to
that last bit there and then jump real
quick like right there and then oh [ __ ]
where'd those guys
oh they got squashed alright well I
guess that's good leader who's gonna be
tight cuz I got that I got the gas
bladder yeah that was it yeah not a good
decision but I did it anyway got a tumor
out of it ow got a tumor out of it whoa
we didn't really grab on to that thing
hey buddy you gonna grab into my arms
yeah Wow this is not what I wanted to
grab on do but I'll take it
don't kill me okay okay wait a minute I
saw no oh boy ah God it was must have
been like milliseconds okay just gotta
wait til the apex this is a Doozer so I
got a what I got to do is I got a
control my mcgurthey throat
by the tiniest terror all what I was
that hothead there was no way that
didn't add it i frickin goddamn it okay
just a little bit
[Music]
oh yes sir yes sir yes hi
yes why okay well Noah I like it
well where am I going oh yes I gotta go
back I gotta do this all right wait here
yeah [ __ ] yep yep that ain't it nope
you see if I'm actually patient about it
I'm actually patient about I'll make it
so anyway that's all for this episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
I really love this game I can actually
go back and talk to that big blob now
that I have over 50 souls for tumors
whatever they are but I'm enjoying this
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
the comments below if you got any more
insight into this story let me know that
as well and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]